et admis pro dans le centre est de
l'Ukraine on va retrouver tout de suite
Lucile Marbeau porte-parole du CICR le
Comité international de la Croix Rouge
Lucile Marbot bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur France 24 les
civils on vient de le voir dans ce sujet
fuit l'est de l'Ukraine malgré les
bombardements commence déroule
concrètement les évacuations quel est le
rôle de la Croix-Rouge sur place
alors écoutez j'ai pu parler aujourd'hui
avec des collègues justement de cela
vient ce que donc les civils
actuellement depuis les derniers jours
sont en train de fuir la zone des trains
par train en bus en voiture par tous les
moyens possibles ce qu'il me disait
c'est que vraiment les villes sont en
train de se vider cela vient parce que
c'est des légionnaire des grandes villes
où on estime quand même ce sont
plusieurs centaines de millions de
personnes actuellement qui sont en train
de fuir et qui sont en train de se
déplacer je suis à admis pro ou un
certain nombre de personnes arrivent
d'après mes dernières informations en
fait ces personnes partent très vite
vers l'ouest pour fuir en fait le plus
vite possible ici nous soutenons depuis
environ maintenant un mois des centres
pour déplacer de personnes vraiment qui
viennent de partout de sauver les
données être de raquif au nord bien
entendu également de Mario Paul plus au
sud et nous nous actuellement nous
soutenons 8 centres mais également un
centre qui coordonne en fait des soutien
dans de nombreuses autres centres et
bien entendu si les personnes venaient
par exemple à rester nous allons
assister nettement plus et augmenter
notre assistance dans la région et il y
a par exemple le la gare depuis
longtemps en fait et un espace de
transit ou les personnes parfois ils
dorment la nuit avant de repartir à
l'aube et ce centre nous le soutenons
également depuis plus d'un mois parce
que disait aussi les collègues c'est que
ces villes commencent à devenir des
villes fantômes seuls les sirènes en
fait rompent le silence et voilà j'ai en
faire bien longtemps tout le possible
oui pardon justement les autorités
ukrainiennes elles redoutent que l'est
du pays ne devienne comme la ville
martyre de Mario Paul Mario Paul ou des
évacuations ont pu avoir lieu hier
mercredi un convoi de cette autobus et
d'environ 40 véhicules privés sous
protection justement du CICR est arrivé
au sud-est de l'Ukraine comment ça s'est
déroulé concrètement
j'étais sur sur ce qu'on voit donc nous
sommes arrivés mardi matin dans les
environs de Belgian ce qu'on nous
attendait déjà des centaines de civils
certains nous disaient qu'ils étaient
déjà là depuis 5h du matin il fait
encore très froid il y avait vraiment un
vent glacial ce matin là ils ont pu du
coup monter dans cette bus 350 personnes
environ beaucoup de familles des
personnes âgées absolument épuisées
physiquement psychologiquement la
majorité venait de Mario Paul beaucoup
en fait fuit la ville à pied donc en
s'exposant vraiment à d'immens dangers
il nous disait à quel point dans la
ville il y a plus d'eau il y a plus
d'électricité il y a plus de médicaments
il y a plus de nourriture il y a presque
plus de connexion il y a quelques lieux
en fait où ils peuvent encore se
connecter mais c'est dehors donc il
s'exposent à ce moment là à des dangers
donc dans l'incapacité de pouvoir
prendre des nouvelles donner des
nouvelles à leur famille et nous sommes
restés sur zone de l'autre côté de la
ligne de front pendant à peu près tous
les jours et ce qu'on voyait c'est qu'il
y avait d'autres zones où effectivement
il y a pas de connectivité et des
personnes sont complètement perduses
c'est-à-dire elles sont réussies à
quitter Mario Paul mais elles savent pas
où aller comment faire les communautés
bien sûr dans les villages environnants
les soutiens nous souhaitons pouvoir du
coup soutenir également ces communautés
en amenant de l'assistance cela aussi
les prix montent elles soutiennent les
communautés il faut qu'elle puisse
continuer bien entendu à le faire donc
on espère pouvoir revenir bien entendu
de l'autre côté de l'Île-de-France
également avec de l'assistance
humanitaire pouvoir aussi atteindre
Mario Paul et pour revenir au convoi
lorsqu'on est parti mardi autour de 10
heures du matin plus tard pardon il
était même environ 13h le temps que les
personnes montent dans dans les bus
cette voiture à ce moment-là de civil
nous accompagner ce qu'on voyait de
l'autre côté en fait c'est que les
voitures affichent qui sont dans les
voitures on voit écrit Dieti Youdi ça
veut dire enfant personne civile et qui
nous ont suivis il y avait moins de 10
voitures au début et lorsqu'on nous
sommes arrivés à sapoliji sans voiture
nous accompagner et on voyait vraiment
la force à ce moment-là de l'emblème
protecteur de la Croix-Rouge les
personnes rejoignaient notre convoi
tellement de monde qu'on a pas pu en
fait passer la ligne de front pendant la
nuit donc on a dormi dans le froid
c'était encore une épreuve
supplémentaire pour ces personnes qui
sont mais absolument épuisés mais déjà
envoyer l'émotion lorsqu'il montait dans
le bus ils étaient en train de pleurer
parce qu'il savait que l'enfant ils
allaient arriver en sécurité et c'est
nous sommes voilà nous souhaitons
vraiment pouvoir reproduire une telle
opération bientôt les personnes ont
besoin de se retrouver en sécurité
beaucoup de personnes nous disaient que
voilà ils allaient rejoindre des
familles un peu plus loin d'autres
n'avaient absolument pas de proposera
aussi de se reposer mais malgré sa
démotion d'être enfin en sécurité
beaucoup beaucoup aussi craignent pour
leurs proches qui sont restés derrière
qui sont restés à Mario Paul j'ai pu
parler avec une jeune
[Musique]